ugh
[Applause]
[Music]
what's up my fellow geeks zacky here
from geek culture and welcome to yet
another cool episode of the tech of the
month for april
now the products that you see here are
probably stuff that we've used in and
out of the office as well as stuff that
we've reviewed on our channel so do
check them out links in the description
below and to start off today's episode
we've got the asus rog flow x13 this is
a 13-inch laptop
but it's powerful yet portable why
because it is a two-in-one convertible
laptop that means you can use this both
as a laptop and a tablet the unit that
we have here has all the bells and
whistles it's got a ryzen 7 5800 hs cpu
a gtx 1650 gpu up to eight gigabytes of
lpddr4x ram and a 512 gigabyte ssd now
you're probably wondering what is this
thing attached to the rog flow now this
is the asus rog xg mobile dock mobile
station and this is actually an external
gpu this houses an rtx 3080 and it's all
connected through asus asus asus asus
owns asus own proprietary egpu interface
so this avoids all the common
bottlenecks that can be found in other
e-gpus
and it gives you the dedicated bandwidth
to enjoy that ultra-spec gaming heavy
video editing whatever you need this
laptop can provide for you now it's not
only about gaming here creatives can
also benefit from the flow x13 it's got
a pantone validated screen panel and it
works with the asus pen so say you're a
graphics designer illustrator interior
designer
this laptop will serve its purpose for
anyone
now if you're looking for style and
power then the refresh 2021 razer blade
series of laptops could be another
choice for you now upgraded with rtx 30
series graphics cards you get an immense
amount of processing power for both
gaming and creating better yet you get a
few choices in terms of specs to cater
to your needs so if you're on a tight
budget if you want ultimate performance
for both work and play there's a razer
blade to cater to anyone's profile so
when it comes to proper webcams there
are few options out there
but why not have a very nice and crisp
4k ultra wide webcam like this one
this is the ava media live streamer cam
513. it comes with a whopping 94 degree
angle wide angle lens which means you
can capture more while streaming or
include more people for video chat and
conferencing it's great for youtubers
and live streamers who want to take
their videos up a notch and like other
webcams where it's usually just a tilt
function this webcam has a 360 degree
swivel design so you can shoot at any
angle you want when needed
it's also got a server arm privacy
shutter to cover the lens and its chem
engine software gives an added touch
with ai framing and ai noise
cancellation so you got a really good
package deal it's also compatible with
skype zoom and recording and live stream
software like obs and xsplit so if
you're planning to get a webcam this is
our recommendation now if you're a fan
of league of legends then kda fans you
can finally rejoice with their own set
of gaming merchandise with logitech
these are just a few in their collection
so if you're looking for a wireless
headset if you're looking for a wireless
mouse heck if you want a gaming mouse
pad logitech has got you covered it's
got style it's got player and being a
kda fan myself these is a must-have get
it
now if you're looking for an ssd upgrade
you've run out of m.2 ssd slots or
perhaps a motherboard doesn't have one
then this is something you might want to
consider
this is a 2.5 inch samsung 870 evo sata
ssd now as the name mentions this plugs
in to your sata cables just like the
ones you have with your hard disk drives
and being a video editor i've got the 4
terabyte version of this and it's a
great option when i've used up all my
m.2 ssd slots there's plenty of space to
put in footage and even games as well
now of course it may not be as fast as
some pcie m.2 ssds but with the 560
megabytes per second reach speed and the
530 megabytes per second write speed
this is good enough for me that i can
even edit 4k footage on the fly and with
that you do get the stability and the
efficiency of an ssd and of course
samsung has also provided a five-year
limited warranty for this so you can be
rest assured they've got a quality
product right here so now we're moving
on to audio and this is the super x5
carrier samba now we have reviewed this
and it's actually our editor's choice as
well so if you want to bring a cinema
like experience to your home then the
super x5 carrier samba is the perfect
choice it's a world's first adobe atmos
speaker system powered by seven drivers
and a wireless 10 inch subwoofer
providing that 5 for 1.2 channel
surround sound it's powerful it's got
plenty of bass and the sound quality is
superb it also has a slew of
connectivity options such as hdmi 2.1
with the capability of 8k pass through
it has bluetooth 5 an optical in a usbc
audio in and a whole lot more now if
you're a late night movie buff like
myself and you don't want to disturb
your love once then this is where the
super x5 technology comes in so with
super x5 technology you can plug in your
headphones into the soundbar and still
have that immersive cinematic sound just
like the soundbar would so do check out
our review on this beast now of course
finishing this video
something a little bit more into
lifestyle
it's
this stinky looking thing is actually a
massage gun and this is called the hydra
gun hair lighter so what it does is that
it helps alleviate muscle soreness and
pain so whether you're in the gym if you
do martial arts or if you're into
esports and you know if you have a stiff
shoulder
if you just did late day like me
then
this helps a lot with easing the pain
and the soreness so let's just turn it
on try it out
[Music]
that's good
so what this does is that helps loosen
the muscle tissues and help increase
blood flow to ease the pain tightness
soreness
shoulder knots or knots by pounding you
with 3
pulses per minute
it's also got six hours of battery life
on a single charge and comes with six
swappable attachment hits for different
users so if you're looking to speed up
recovery then this hydra gun is quite an
impressive piece of tech for your pre
and post workouts and of course it's a
better investment than spending top
dollar on the masseuse
so all in all these products have
definitely caught our eye this month
some of these products might lean more
onto the premium side of things but if
you're wondering whether you should pick
one up for yourselves you can check out
our reviews in the description below
there will be some links to these
products so do check them out it's a
great way to support our channel and if
you like to support our channel in
another way then consider subscribing
and smash that bell icon so you can be
notified every time we upload new videos
until then this is zaki signing off
adios muchachos
you